for months the tech has she has been
battling allegations of mistreatment and
sexual harassment of women in the
workplace more than two dozen women
entrepreneurs' recently spoke to the New
York Times about being sexually harassed
by investors in high-profile venture
capitalists and another tech executive
quit in recent days over sexual
harassment allegations venture
capitalist dave McClure of the company
500 startups apologized in a blog post
and he wrote I am a creep I'm sorry his
resignation is the latest in what seems
to be a trend in Silicon Valley New York
Times correspondent and CBS News
contributor that's Joni Kanter joins us
once again at the table to discuss it
seems we're discussing this issue too
many times with you Jodi Cameron so do
you call it a trend in Silicon Valley
has it been happening all along and we
didn't know about it or it's been
happening and now we're hearing about it
and women are speaking up it's been
happening all along and women are
speaking up I've had lots of
conversations over the years with women
who told me horror stories about being
sexually harassed in Silicon Valley but
then you get to the moment of truth as a
journalist and you say will you go on
the record in the past many women
declined now that's changing what it's
changing my colleague Katie Benner had
some really hairy days of sexual
harassment and it was almost like a
waterfall effect where you know the
women were coming forward together it
wasn't really about any of their
individual stories it was about the
pattern and they had the documentation
by the way which did not look good in
the cold harsh light of the New York
Times print and basically these messages
from guys saying you know coming on to
them and remember the context these were
women entrepreneurs who are trying to
build companies and they needed funding
so they went to these powerful male
venture capitalists and they said here's
my business case here's the amount of
money I need here's what I'll do with it
most of them were men the venture
capital exactly and the men's response
was to come on to them so it left the
women in a terrible position well and
they're already at a disadvantage
because as the numbers show female
entrepreneurs received about 1.5 billion
in funding last year compared to 58
point two billion for men so they face
an uphill struggle and then if someone's
hitting on you while you're trying to
get money for your business if they feed
off this unbalance in a power
structure exactly and there's so much
talk about getting more women into the
tech pipeline about STEM education but
you can send all the women you want to
computer coding classes if those women
are going to be hit on when they try to
get capital then they're gonna encounter
very severe what is it about that
culture is it really that different from
any other industry I think part of why
this is happening now is that we're
seeing a conversation across industries
in the last year we've seen two major
CEOs who have lost their jobs in part
because of sexual harassment Foxx's
Roger Ailes and ubers Travis kalanick
that Travis wasn't accused though a
secretary he wasn't accused directly but
it was a problem at his company and so
can you really name another era in which
this has taken down CEOs things are
beginning to shift and most importantly
the women feel like they're going to be
believed if they come forward there do
seem to be some exceptions to what seems
to be the rule that is Reed Hoffman for
one who found it linked to anything what
he's talking about this decency pledge
signing a decency place what would that
mean and what would the punishment be of
you if you violate it the reason the
decency pledge is so important is that
it's just articulating a common sense
rule which is that no woman or man for
that matter in the workplace should feel
any kind of sexual pressure by the boss
whether the boss is a manager or whether
it's an investor who has a lot of money
to offer now that sounds like a very
common-sense thing it does a decency
pledge to do the right thing Jodi I'm
thinking what is that going to do but
apparently it is necessary for there to
be sort of clearly articulated rules of
the road in this department well
hopefully a lot of the great reporting
by the New York Times is putting people
on notice thank you yeah great reporting
Thank You Jodi always good to have you
here